[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
well welcome everyone it's so wonderful
to see
all of your faces this is one of those
times that i really love
zoom when i get to see our whole
community together on one screen
so um as as most of you
here know the our our program
is a fairly intense two years
and this is always one of the you know
if not the
highlight of every year is to see all of
the uh the members of a cohort
um present the work that's come to
fruition over the course of these two
years
two years is a you know a lot can happen
in two years as we know
um uh but also two years can go
can go by very very quickly and we ask
a lot of our students in that period of
time
our students come in with an idea or two
or three
um or more and then very quickly we
we ask them to focus in on a thesis
topic and and then do the research
and then do the writing and you know
that happens
in a at a real clip um
and i'm especially uh
happy to be here for this cohort because
last year was the first time that i
taught the
second semester course in which students
are asked to first
formulate a thesis proposal and so it's
really exciting
to uh to be able to see where things
have
have come to from that point that early
point in this process
the way that we're going to do this
today is that we will um
i think most of you probably have the
schedule we're going to have three
presentations in the morning session
then we'll have a break and four more
presentations in the afternoon
for each uh student that's presenting
i'm gonna
call on their uh their thesis advisor
to do a short intro and um
and then i'll just try to keep things
going
uh as we as we move along so
um the our first student up
this morning is roya musa poor and um
i would like to ask uh justin to
um get us started
welcome everyone really wonderful to be
here can everybody hear me
yep yep terrific um yeah roya has been
just such a crucial and fabulous part of
our team for the past two years we're
incredibly grateful for all of our
contributions
i know that there are lots of folks from
the teaching systems lab here today who
are really excited to hear more about
her thesis
which is born you know starts from a
personal experience that kind of got
underneath roya's skin
and she really demonstrates in a
powerful way what some
intensive research to try to understand
uh things in the media ecosystem
that feel problematic to us can look
like after deep study
so really proud of roya's work and
excited to hear it in its uh newest form
all right so i'm going to pass it to
roya the title
of roya's thesis is cashing in on
student data
standardized testing and predatory
college marketing
in the united states all right
thank you i'm just gonna take one second
i'll apologize first off because i have
a couple of screens here so if you see
me look over
to one of them don't be alarmed
coming up okay great
well good morning everyone thank you to
vivek and shannon and justin for the
intro and for setting this all up
um i think it's been it's been a wild
year to be doing all this research
and i think i speak for all of my
classmates and saying thanks for
supporting us
through all of this while we've been
scattered across the country
um so today i want to introduce you to
some core aspects of my thesis research
so i'll set this up with a bit of a
personal story
to tell you why i'm motivated to study
the standardized testing and predatory
marketing that happens around the
college admissions process
so 10 or so years ago i was a high
school junior
starting my college process and as the
oldest of three i was the first to go
through the process
and i had really quite excellent access
to
college counseling at my high school but
i felt like i had a lot to learn and i
know that my parents are on right now
and i'm sure that they would probably
agree with that so when i took the sat
for the first time i realized i was
eligible to sign up for something called
the student search service which
is a college board service that provides
students with personalized college
recommendations
and all kinds of outreach from
universities so i really eagerly signed
up
i was excited to get mailers and emails
from universities that thought i should
apply
so i want to kind of take you back in
time and show you what that looked like
on one of the first days i started
receiving emails from universities
so here's my inbox as a high school
junior i would say it's pretty typical
i have emails from concert venues 17
magazine
groupon but what really strikes me here
is the number of universities that that
had emailed me on this day
so not long after i started receiving
these emails i actually revoked my
consent
from the program i found the emails
overwhelmingly annoying
and really so generic that they provided
me with very little information that was
actually aiding my college search
but i continued to receive emails and i
even reached out to the college board to
try to figure out
why and they actually confirmed that i
was not subscribed to any email
newsletters at all
later on that year they emailed me three
separate times to ask if i wanted to
rejoin the student search service
which to me was proof that i wasn't
actively signed up even though i
continued to receive emails
i ended up actually receiving emails for
nearly a year after revoking my
permission from participation
so 10 years later i found myself really
puzzled by that fact
why did i continue receiving emails
after revoking my consent
where was my personal information in
this process as a high school or a minor
and how was it being used
so after all of this time a lot more
school and much much more reading
i think i finally have the right words
to describe what this was
so in my thesis i argue that programs
like the college board student
search service facilitate something
called surveillance capitalism which is
a phrase coined by a harvard researcher
and professor shoshan azubov
i'll explain a little bit more about
surveillance capitalism in a couple
minutes
but at the most basic level surveillance
capitalism is the idea that your
personal information
traits and behavior can be rendered into
data
feeding into predictive products that
help large companies provide things like
targeted advertising
and then ultimately allows those
companies to make predictions about your
future behavior and even shape your
future behavior
so i argue in my thesis that while we
need more transparency around these
practices
our ultimate need is greater regulation
of companies and organizations
so i see my contribution to academic
discourse around surveillance capitalism
and
more broadly what i'm referring to here
is critical data studies
um i see this as a key example of
surveillance capitalism that i hope to
convince you
in the course of this talk at least is
entirely unethical
and the potential implications for such
practices
so very briefly just a quick overview of
kind of where i'll take you in the next
half an hour or so
i'm going to take a moment to just
situate this thesis within the
sort of broader academic discourse and
then i'll introduce you to the privacy
framework that i build
um through my thesis to rely upon to
analyze the actions of the college board
very briefly touch on methodology and
then really dive into two key
case studies involving the student
search service
and then talk about how those kind of
translate into predatory marketing and
the ethical implications for data
collection and analysis
in this process finally i'll talk
about sort of where do we go from here
what are the takeaways
so i see this thesis and this is this is
sort of a
question i i go back um back to pretty
often within media studies at least i
see this thesis sitting at the
intersection of what i'm calling
education critical data studies and law
and public policy
so i draw from each field in order to
understand the implications for programs
like the college board student search
service
in the broader discourse around data
collection algorithmic decision making
and predatory marketing
so these are some examples of who i've
been reading for the last couple of
years
and i want to bring these up as
individuals thinking critically about
data studies in
various spaces so on the right you see
justin's book
failure to disrupt within education we
have people thinking about this within
financial institutions
on social media and in many cases the
implications for
what all of these individuals are
studying tend to impact people of color
and people impacted by poverty most
directly
so i'll take a second you see on the
left surveillance capitalism
um to introduce you to a little bit more
about that
um so because my thesis uses a case
study around the college board to
demonstrate what i'm calling
an act of surveillance capitalism
impacting k-12 students
i'm going to take a moment to outline a
critical transition that shashana zubov
outlines in her book on surveillance
capitalism
and so i want to explain what she calls
the behavioral value reinvestment cycle
which is the beginnings of surveillance
capitalism
so in this cycle and this is a figure
from her book on the left
when information is collected from
individuals especially in an online
setting
it's rendered or turned into data
analyzed
and then used to improve upon that
surface for that service for an
individual
so there's a certain amount of data
that's being rendered that doesn't get
used and this is at the top of the cycle
and shashana zuboff considers that to be
data exhaust or surplus information
which is a byproduct of this cycle
at some point companies realize that
that very small amount of data exhaust
what we're now characterizing as
behavioral surplus was actually
enormously profitable
so in the second figure on the right we
see this original cycle
the behavioral value reinvestment cycle
actually on the bottom
of this much larger image so it used to
be considered exhaust
is now fed into a much larger cycle
this is not intended to benefit the user
at all this entirely is intended to
benefit a company
so data previously rendered as extra
exhaust
is fed into this much larger system that
can predict
our behavior as users and that can be
extremely profitable
so i think what's important to recognize
here is while this does feed into
marketing and advertisements we might
expect
this cycle really goes beyond that so
this new marketplace here on the top
left of the figure
operates around future behavior so it's
probabilistic in nature
and companies that make the best
predictions about people's future
behavior end up winning in the end
so that way marketing and advertisement
can be used to shape people's behavior
based on predictions and how people act
this is far from the predictions of ai
taking over the worlds that many have
made but it speaks to a significant
reduction in individuals autonomy over
their actions
so what's the ultimate outcome here
individuals lose their autonomy over
daily decision making
and while companies like google have
been doing this for years
i argue that we can and we should do our
best to minimize the impacts of this
on other aspects of society such as
within our k-12 and higher education
systems
so now that we have a better idea of the
core tenets and impacts of surveillance
capitalism i want to pivot back to the
college board
and share some of the theoretical basis
for my research that has helped me
understand
my own relationship as a high schooler
with the college board
and the wider implications for the
college board student and university
facing services
so in order to do so i built a model of
privacy based on the work of two
individuals helen nissenbaum and arie
ezra waldman
and i use this model of privacy
throughout my research to analyze
different aspects of behavior from the
college board
so here on the left kind of upper left
is ari ezra waldman's privacy as trust
and this model is one in which we
recognize that all of our relationships
personal professional etc
are built on trust so we build a sense
of trust with individuals or
organizations to share any kind of
personal information
just as we do with doctors or with
financial advisors
and in those situations those
individuals are legally required to keep
our information
private so this is exactly what waldman
calls privacy is trust and it's enforced
legally
nissan nissenbaum on the bottom right
here um her model of privacy as
contextual integrity
is one under which the distribution of
data
can happen under two specific norms and
you have to meet both of those norms for
distribution to be okay and those are
called appropriate
appropriateness and flow so they help us
ask questions such as
is the data being collected in a certain
situation appropriate
and then is the transfer of that data
from one party to another appropriately
so just as an example it might be
perfectly appropriate for a grocery
store to collect information on the
types of food people buy
in order to restock the proper amounts
so that they always have enough in stock
but it would be less appropriate for
that same grocery store to
ask patrons of the store for a list of
all of the restaurants they like within
a one-mile radius of their home
similarly it might be reasonable for
that grocery store to share the purpose
the purchasing habits of patrons with
their supplier for restocking purposes
but it wouldn't be appropriate flow or
distribution
for that supplier to then share that
information one step
further with patrons health insurance
providers
so here i have sort of my sketched out
model of privacy that i use throughout
my thesis
and i'm arguing for combined framework
of privacy and distrust and privacy as
contextual
integrity so i'll start on the left in
terms
of assumptions so when we analyze this
instance of surveillance capitalism
within the college process
we have to assume in some sense that
data sharing will continue
so this draws directly from waldman's
work
second we have to assume that students
and their parents
and even their teachers and
administrators are not always aware of
the data sharing that happens
and how these data are shared and this
is exactly what happened to me as a
student
when i was in high school so next are
sorts of requirements
for data sharing of some sort are as
follows exactly the norms of
appropriateness and flow as defined by
nissin bone
so we ask again are the data collected
appropriate to a specific context
and then when considering distribution
or flow is that distribution appropriate
and how can relationships of trust
enable and constrain distribution so
finally and this has been sort of my
biggest question throughout all of this
how do we actually do this um so i
say through two primary methods and the
first is transparency
which helps minimize any difference of
information between a data provider
and a data collector and the second and
arguably most important method
is through legal enforcement and this
echoes waldman's work as well
so we need to build in legal mechanisms
that actually enforce data privacy
legislation
in order to minimize potential harm to
students
so i want to briefly highlight the
different methodologies i use in this
research just to show you a bit of the
varied approach that i take
um so i rely upon historical research
in order to look at the history of
standardized testing normalization of
data collection within our school
systems
policy analysis to review all kinds of
federal and state
laws surrounding student data privacy
and then i
dive into primary research in order to
analyze
documents that are associated with the
student search service in the college
board and that even includes some of my
own documentation from 10 years ago and
then interviews to sort of situate this
work
contextually within the the voices of
individuals connected to the college
admissions process so
college enrollment consultants college
counselors
admissions officers etc
so now that you have an understanding of
what i'm using to analyze the actions of
the college board i'll bring you back to
my example of the college board student
search service
to specifically look at two examples of
how the college board violates that
framework of privacy
that i just built so one example relates
the inclusion of transparency in the
privacy framework and the second uses my
own experience participating in the
student search service as a high
schooler
to illustrate a violation of the norm of
distribution
so as i mentioned before the student
search service is the college board's
flagship program to provide students
with free personalized college
recommendations
when a student participates in a college
board exam like the sat or psat
a student can opt into this service and
provide all kinds of information about
themselves to the college board
such as their address their ethnicity
gender
financial aid need and educational
aspirations and interests
the college board then takes this
information plugs it into its
proprietary recommender systems
and then provides students with
recommendations for college
however to kind of pivot towards the
college-facing
service the college board also collects
this information
and i'll quote here to create the
largest most effective admissions search
database
in the united states so that database it
then markets
to universities and other loosely
educational organizations
through the college board search and
these organizations and universities
have the option to lease student names
from the college board
in a variety of ways but at the most
basic level
it costs colleges about 50 cents per
name
to gain student information as written
here
on the bottom with the college-facing
example and these are actual quotes
that the college board uses to market
these two services whether it's student
facing or college facing
the college board is very explicit about
marketing the college board search as an
enrollment solution to help universities
market themselves to students
and what i think is most striking about
this quote on the bottom is specifically
this focus on
marketing return on investment this is
not towards the universities
this is not intended to benefit the
students
so we know that about 80 of students
using the college board opt into the
student search service at some time
even if we approximate this based on the
number of people taking the sat
in one year this is about 1.8 million
students
that's a big data set but research shows
that the student search service doesn't
really benefit students at all
so according to an internal college
board paper cited by the wall street
journal in 2019
a student whose information is sold as
part of the student search service
is about 0.1 likelier to apply to a
university
from which they've received marketing
and materials of some sort
and only about 0.2 percent likelier to
enroll in one of those universities
so who benefits from the student search
service
it's purely the college board and
universities
the college board brings in about 10 to
11
of the organization's revenue every year
from the college board search and
associated programs
universities gain access to large
quantities of data
student information for marketing and
analytics individual
students are barely impacted at least in
a positive way
so this i argue is exactly what feeds
into surveillance capitalism
large amounts of data are collected and
distributed to third parties in this
case
universities and scholarship
organizations rendered at scale
these data can be used to make all kinds
of predictions about incoming students
who will be successful who might drop
out who might major in what subject
who can pay and who can't
so i want to take you through my two
small case studies to illustrate some of
the challenges surrounding the college
board student search service and college
board search
so this slide kind of demonstrates the
kinds of information shared either
towards students or for parents
about the about the student search
service so a student considering signing
up for the student search service online
is told that colleges pay for the
service
online however parents are not told that
colleges pay for their children's
information
through the student search service and
college board search unless they
navigate to a separate web page
where they're told that universities pay
a license fee to participate
this says nothing about the explicit per
name basis of the service
so in a test setting on the other hand
students are not told that colleges pay
for their information
and this is not in the proctor script so
a proctor administering the exam
will never say anything in the entire
exam that says that there's a cost
associated with the service to
universities
if and when parents are provided with a
consent form for their children to
participate
which is not required on the federal
level but certain states or districts
might require
they're told the same information as the
faq online
which is that universities pay some kind
of license fee to participate
so this difference in information is
very similar to what economists call
an information asymmetry and one that
makes it very difficult for individuals
to proceed within what we're calling a
relationship built on trust
between a student and the college board
or parent in the college board
so the college board explicitly holds
more information about these programs
than students and parents
who are most responsible for consenting
to the service
so in doing so the college board has
created a reseller's market between
students and universities one which the
larger customer
the university will default as the most
important
the information students are provided
with in different situations to
participate in this market
is quite minimal but the lack of
transparency between the college board
and students
is missing what shashana zubov in her
book on surveillance capitalism
refers to as the shadow text and that's
this
individual invisible understanding of
what's really happening
under the surface so the college board
tells students that the organization is
helping them
but the shadow text here tells a very
different story
that students are helping universities
market themselves
and make predictions about their
incoming classes of students
this is possible simply because of the
nature of a reseller's market
where the larger customer is more likely
to benefit from
than the smaller customer and in this
case the smaller customer isn't really a
customer at all
and is just a supplier the students
so my second example is around the norm
of flow
and here's a brief snippet of how the
college board allows students to opt out
of the student search service
so while the college board claims to
lease student information
i'm arguing that the organization
explicitly violates the normal flow or
distribution
outlined earlier by misinforming
students and parents about how they
distribute information
so as a reminder the norm of flow
circled here on the bottom
is one of two norms described by helen
nissenbaum's privacy is contextual
integrity
and this asks whether the actual
distribution of data from one party to
another
the flow of information whether that's
appropriate
so back to the college board a student
signs up for the student search service
just as i did as a high school and
likely many of my classmates
consenting to the distribution of their
data the college board by claiming to
lease
student information implies that such
data sharing is temporary
if a student were to agree to such
distribution of their information
then it would be expected that after a
student revokes consent
ie opts out of the program that their
student data would be removed
however the college board while claiming
to lease student data
is explicitly giving universities data
for a cost
which is just selling so the college
board will not redistribute
student data after a student opts out
but just as highlighted here
in this faq on opting out of the program
universities that already have student
information
can continue to use that information and
reach out to students
so to provide a parallel situation
which is especially funny given that
it's snowing outside for many of us
today
imagine you rent a car on vacation this
is the wishful thinking of the day
you've signed a lease with a rental
agency on the last day of your lease
you're required to return the car if you
keep the car
after your lease ends you're likely
going to face pretty large penalties
as you've violated the terms of your
lease
so with the college board a student
revoking consent from the student search
service
is the end of a lease if a university
maintains access to student information
and continues to use it then by
definition
if that is within the scope of allowance
according to the college board
then the college board is very
explicitly selling rather than leasing
student information
and this feeds directly into
surveillance capitalism
an individual signs up for a service
thinking it will provide one specific
thing
and unknowingly becomes a part of a
completely different process
a student can individually unsubscribe
from university's email lists one at a
time
which in many cases could be in the tens
fifties hundreds of universities
reaching out
but that student has absolutely no idea
how that university might continue to
use
their information and this misdirection
is a classic component of surveillance
capitalism
students supply their data for free into
an economy that ends up feeding off of
their data for a price
so these types of data can then be used
in different forms of marketing and
analysis
not unlike the emails that i received
from universities 10 years ago
and so all of this marketing happens
within a field called enrollment
management
enrollment management as an industry
helps exists to help colleges recruit
and retain
students so one educational consultant i
spoke with shared with me that this
extends to a college's image or brand
and maintaining prestige and publicity
is very important for colleges both for
non-profit and for-profit universities
so at many universities this extends
beyond what we might think of
as students showing demonstrated
interest by attending an information
session or participating in a campus
visit
this has even turned into measuring
student engagement with a university
through clicks marketing campaigns and
metrics
so there are many companies that provide
these services to universities
and some of them such as slate here on
the right provide not only marketing
services
but also what was described to me by an
admissions officer at a large university
as crm services or customer relationship
management
so here students are customers for
universities and universities need to
catch their eye
but looking more specifically at the
quote i've highlighted here on the right
above slate
many of these companies provide all
kinds of analytical services
through data dashboards and other
systems that allow universities to make
predictions about student outcomes and
success
so this form of prediction is exactly
what many scholars have learned about
taking personal information in order to
make predictions about which students
will be successful
graduate or be able to pay many times
this even happens at schools
historically known for discrimination
so this is what shoshan azuboff refers
to as rendition of data into prediction
products
and then even further behavior
modification
student information is used for
predictions that allow universities to
market themselves to students
and gain customers through appealing to
students it makes us ask the question
do students maintain autonomy in this
process and what does this set
students up for in the future
so in certain cases the types of
marketing
previously mentioned can be helpful
and they have that that type of
marketing has the ability to bring in
populations of students
otherwise marginalized from higher
education
but in many cases this marketing can be
extremely dangerous
so the for-profit university industry is
a discriminatory and predatory industry
that preys on students
these schools often target students
based on zip codes for recruitment to
figure out which students might be
eligible for federal loans
interviewees i spoke with shared of the
focus on recruiting military veterans as
well
as veterans come with some kind of
educational funding through the gi bill
so these types of universities use
large amounts of student data in order
to optimize their potential incoming
class for profit
and programs such as the student search
service have the ability to enable their
actions
so here's just a little bit of a doodle
of where student data might go
in this type of a situation so at the
federal level
students are not legal stewards of their
own data within school systems
until they're 18. but exceptions are
made in many cases
when organizations are deemed
educational in some sense
organizations like the college board act
as middlemen in these processes
distributing highly personal information
to other organizations
and never asking for the data back so
this third level of organization or
university here
is now no longer subject to the same
level of legal oversight of how data is
used
and this level acts opaquely and it's
really anyone's guess how information
might be used and further distributed
after it reaches that level
so what we do know is that student data
is not used
only to recruit diverse applicants but
in many cases
it's also used within enrollment
management systems
for predatory lending practices for use
in predictive machine learning models
and in targeted advertisement
so organizations such as the college
board misdirect students
to share personal information and enable
the for-profit university in predatory
lending industries
feeding into surveillance capitalism
involving k-12 students
so where do we go from here
so we know that organizations like the
college board are enabling this
often inappropriate distribution of data
that really does have the impact
the potential to impact someone's life
enormously
so i argue for three primary action
items around this
so first we need to build some kind of
transparency of company data policies
in order to clearly communicate what
companies hope to do with
student data this goes back to the way
that organizations like the college
board describe
their own actions when students and
parents
see different information when trying to
learn about services
where parents are not provided with
readable consent forms or data policies
when a student takes something like the
sat within school
there's an information asymmetry created
that makes it
quite impossible for individuals to make
educated decisions about how to act
and whether to sort of enter this
relationship with an organization
so the college board has created a
resellers market through the student
search service
and it provides great benefit to itself
and to university customers
while providing little to students in
the process
second there needs to be greater
oversight of organizations collecting
student data
and enforcement of laws and legally
binding agreements such as something
called the student privacy pledge
which is a pledge that lots of
educational organizations and companies
have signed
including the college board that says
that they don't sell student data
and when an organization signs this type
of a pledge
it is actually legally enforceable
through the ftc
but we've seen very minimal enforcement
if if any
of these types of pledges already so
third
i argue that we need greater privacy
protections for students
and this really extends to consumer data
privacy as well
this is something individuals and
companies agree with
individuals feel better protected
knowing their individual information is
protected
and companies would prefer to comply
with federal laws
rather than the fractured landscape of
individual state privacy laws
so these takeaways are by no means
exhaustive
but they feed into a greater area of
consumer data privacy and
and lots of individuals and activists
fighting to protect
consumers data more broadly so i hope
that i've convinced you that programs
such as the college board student search
service are unethical
and feed into surveillance capitalism
surrounding our k-12 students by
creating this opportunity for student
information to be rendered
into predictive products helping
universities make predictions about
student success to inform their
marketing
we need to regulate these programs and
others in order to make sure children
and parents understand how their
information is being used
the college board over time has become
ingrained as this odd not-for-profit
acting as a gatekeeper to higher
education within our k-12 and higher
education
um areas and my hope is that by fighting
back against surveillance capitalism
within our educational spaces
we can ensure more equitable access to
higher education for students
and minimize the impact of predatory
practices within the college application
process
thank you
all right thank you roya we have a
little bit of time for questions and
and so for those of you who are
on screen if you can use your your hands
uh your either virtual or actual hands
um i will try to keep track of the order
that they're coming in
so first um uh william
[Music]
roya thanks that was that was terrific
it's terrific it's important it's
logical and it's ethical
and the legal system i'm afraid is
neither of those you've made a
compelling case
logically and and ethically um the
student privacy pledge is
is an interesting example uh if there is
indeed violation here
there's a class action suit waiting to
happen and this is a relatively
uh well-endowed organization why hasn't
that happened
has it happened what's the legal advice
on this where because i'm sure there's
some
some mighty powerful loopholes that are
blocking this and that i think
it is exactly those those powerful
loopholes that have been the problem
so there have been a couple of cases
that have actually been tossed
out where people have said you know the
college board has sold my information
and i would like to sue them because of
this there's there's a class action
right now
that's being argued i think it was filed
last
spring um that we we don't know about
yet but the
the actual issue and this is i think the
most challenging thing about doing this
type of work
has been that no one has been able to
demonstrate in the legal court
actual harm from this very directly
because there's no direct
kind of tracking that's possible from an
individual student into some kind of
college's system
into some kind of marketing or you know
a for-profit university's
predatory lending practices so courts
have thrown these issues out purely on
the technicality of
demonstrated harm and this has been
and you you could ask justin this
question as well and he and i have gone
back and forth on this many times
in terms of how do you sort of
beat one of these issues before you see
the implications happen and we've seen
the implications of
for-profit colleges and we know that
they target
students based on where they are and we
know that zip code
has a really high correlation with race
and so it ends up
impacting people of color most directly
but it's almost like there needs to be
some massive
investigative journalism project that
that is able to actually get someone to
say
from point a to point b yes we have this
direct
link because we have people who are
saying we need better protections for
students
and we have people saying we have this
enormous
industry of predatory lending but
the actual connection at least in a
court has not yet
been made is what i would say and it's
something i think about and i'm thinking
about as i'm doing all of my
revisions now as well thank you
i think andrew was next and then t.l
well
thanks um so
i just want to make sure i understood
one thing that you said that
there is no benefit basically to schools
in terms of
application rates and yield on this data
that they got
no that that hasn't that so it hasn't
i wanted yeah i wanted to understand
this point zero one and point zero two
yeah yeah this is a great thing to
clarify
so for an individual student there's
very little impact but for universities
that has a huge impact because you
basically can
scale up while it might for an
individual student have a really minimal
impact on
what ends up happening in terms of their
application
when schools are buying hundreds of
thousands of names
all of a sudden a very little impact for
one student
over that hundred thousand two hundred
thousand or more
number of names does scale up so it is
this is a there's actually a chapter
in kathy o'neill's weapons of math
destruction
um that discusses this exactly from the
perspective of
yield and of the number of applicants to
university
um and i think this all sort of started
in the 70s and 80s
when u.s news and world report started
reporting
um college rankings and this sort of
directly fed into that at the very
initial outset
and then real quick uh second question
what's the history of selling data
because i know the college board's been
around since
early 1900s i think and it was set up as
a way to
basically create the sat to standardize
testing for admissions offices
um but there must have been a
presentation that somebody gave at some
point saying oh i've got this great idea
we should
yeah so yeah this started in 1972
um under i think it was called the
student data questionnaire at the time
it was a little bit different
but what's really interesting to track
sort of in the history of this
is that while the college board has been
at least
somewhat consistent about you know
leasing student data
media reporting on this service has
always used the word cell
there has been never there's never been
a point where someone had said yeah
they're leasing student data and we
totally agree with them
um but it has always been since the
absolute very beginning
it's been the college board selling
student data selling student data over
and over again
yeah right thanks
um i think tl was next if tl still has a
question well i guess um maybe i'll just
i don't hopefully you can hear me okay
that was really interesting presentation
and i love the kind of close
read and analysis of the system and how
the data is flowing i guess my question
might have actually been
slightly answered in piggybacking on
andrews because i
it felt like there was an implied model
of
of human agency running through the talk
at the same time what i felt was
um some some undermining of the actual
efficacy of the predictive system and i
think this is one of the
the interesting critiques that's
emerging is it's a little bit
sometimes a hype and a promise
of prediction that doesn't actually pay
off i think this is one of the things
we're seeing around
the critique critiques of predictive
policing where
actually there's lots of ways you can
poke holes in the
kind of impact and efficacy of those
systems so i don't know if i have a way
to ask this
quite right i mean um you might have
addressed it with andrews if
if you have a sense of where my question
and critique was heading i'd be i'd be
happy to hear more thoughts but
um you know i do i do wonder sometimes
these systems a little bit
promise more than they actually can pay
off
um so anyway i'll just i'll leave it at
that
yeah so i think what what sort of
strikes me about
this in terms of where the predictive
models in a sense are coming in
is that they're happening at sort of all
different levels the college board has
their own system the college board ends
up maintaining
all of this information and they have an
entire
research organization within the
organization itself
that does all kinds of analysis with
this data um
but i think what's what's challenging is
every single university that
has data in this regard is using it in a
totally different way and has a totally
different
system um one of the universities that i
spoke with
um i spoke with a researcher who said
you know we know for us that student
success
correlates really really strongly with
sat scores
while you know other universities you
know i went to bowdoin bowdoin said
there a very long time ago we're no
longer going to require test scores
because we don't think that they really
have an impact and at both of those
universities you have
highly successful students highly
intelligent students
and in one system they've decided that
their predictions are that
the the sat scores really matter and in
others they've decided that
it doesn't really matter at all so it's
i don't know if this entirely answers
your question but it's
it's very fractured and i think sort of
i
i noticed in the chat justin has been
doing a great job of moderating
moderating the chat for me thank you
justin
um but one of my colleagues at tsl at
the lab
um asked you know should we just be
calling for the abolishment of the
college board
and there are sort of two different ways
that this could happen i
personally you know we've seen over the
last year how many schools are just
totally fine without asking for for sat
scores and this year has really been a
reckoning for that i think mit just
announced the other day
that they're not going to be asking for
sat scores again
so it is this odd time of being able to
say
maybe we should just start getting rid
of this organization
but even then there are plenty of other
places that have gotten in trouble
before
that have been collecting student data
in other ways
that have gotten you know they've
they've run into issues legally
um surveying students for personal
information
and they're still selling data to
universities so so it's sort of
the the models are all spread out but
the data is
coming in from very very many places
that are sort of
doing it under the books
can i just say i appreciate that answer
and i think it points to part of what
i'm
i'm
trying to think through is you know
there's a long history of the sociology
of education and educators themselves
critiquing systems
what i'm wondering is if the theoretical
models that
come with something like zuboff's
surveillance capitalism
are a perhaps a more a bigger and a kind
of
unwieldy more innovative wieldy hammer
than we actually need to make the
critiques we want to make
because there are really interesting
theories of agency
packaged in and i you know i love zubov
especially her
first book but i mean so anyway so thank
you for that answer because it begins to
get at
uh some of what i think i was trying a
little bit sloppily pointing to
all right eric and then we will be
moving on to our next
uh presentation my question actually
builds on the some of the stuff you just
talked about there at the end which was
the past
year um yeah there's been a lot of
disruption yeah that most schools
haven't required any standardized exams
over the last year
and there's some data starting to emerge
on that in terms of what it's done for
diversity
um uh and um and
you know that it's a little bit hard to
tease out exactly because there's also
uh you know pandemic impacts on that as
well in terms of who's applied to where
but sort of how do you you know it's
been a massive experiment do you sort of
see that as an
as a disruption to the entire system or
is it gonna
uh sort of settle back down to
equilibrium i would love to see it as a
disruption to the system
i i don't think we're far enough out yet
to see
how it might impact um i've i've traced
a little bit
not in the scope of this work but just
in my own reading trying to follow
what's happening this year
and i read an article a few weeks ago
that
specifically talked about how you know
we've seen application numbers
jump enormously at all these sort of
elite universities that are not
requiring test scores but what we've
also seen is
is numbers drop terribly at community
colleges
and all kinds of sort of other less not
the non-four-year universities
which i think are still extremely
important parts
of our educational system um and and
trade schools and such
so i think it is sort of a reckoning
point and we're
we're not yet far enough to see how it
goes but
i would be really saddened to see oh
well now that we don't have sat scores
let's say hypothetically
we have everyone applying for this set
of schools they all get that much more
competitive and then we see
all these universities which are
catering to non-traditional students
which are catering to sort of students
who need
who are going to jump from an associates
to a four-year
in the way that i think like the uc
system has done really well over the
years
i would be really sad to see those sort
of dwindle
because of all of a sudden this focus on
elite schools without test scores so it
really could go
either way
all right thank you so much roya yeah
thank you